[Music]
hey Luke here with the October boys
YouTube channel and I'm taking another
crack at building an African hunting
spear so for those of you who follow my
channel you'll know that a little while
ago I tried building an African hunting
spear and had mixed results it was a
load of fun and I'll put a link in the
description to that video so if you
haven't seen that video yet go check it
out but I learned a lot of things from
that project and I want to build another
spirit I want I want to improve it I
just know I can do better so last time I
did this project the biggest mistake I
made is I designed the blade end of the
spear with a tang instead of a cup I
should have made a cup because it's just
stronger and less likely to break but I
didn't have a piece of equipment to help
form that Cup I needed a cone-shaped
piece of Steel to use as a mold so I
bought this 24 inch piece of one inch
diameter 1080 steel rod and I'm going to
beat this thing into a shape of a cone
to make the tool I need to do this
project
[Applause]
[Music]
Rosalie dislocated
[Music]
well guys I need some more leaf spring
steel and so we are here at the junkyard
with my boy Nathan we're gonna see what
we can find Tommy was very upset he
didn't get to come he loves this place
as he should it's awesome oh look
there's that's what we need right there
[Music]
father stays in time too
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
well guys it's been a long day I'm
completely out of charcoal and I am very
tired I've made a lot of progress but
I'm gonna have to pick this up again
tomorrow I think I might need a shower -
well guys last night I was up at 2:00
a.m. feeding jacob and i was thinking
about this project and I had an idea I
think I need to adjust my tool
[Music]
alright guys it's day three and I've
decided I'm gonna do this all over again
I'm just not happy with how this turned
out here I might mount it on something
just for fun but it's not good enough
[Music]
yeah I got the four drawer in the day
does a little hole out for better
airflow that's a firework contains we're
heating up real fast
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
alright one of the things I'm doing
different is I've got this little piece
of paper I'm using as a measuring gauge
I took and I wrap this around the
thickest part of my little mold here and
figured out how much material it takes
to wrap around this thing and so this is
the width that's what I'm shooting for
is the width between this piece of paper
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
well I am so happy that I redid this and
it just looks a load better and it went
a lot faster looks really good look look
right down there so now I just need to
go and form the neck and then the actual
head right here
[Music]
well guys it's the end of the third day
working on this project but I'm really
pleased with this I've drawn out the
metal about five inches got a longer
stem than I did on my other sphere which
I wanted tomorrow morning I'm gonna cut
out the rest of the blade with the angle
grinder just forge up the edge shouldn't
take too much time well guys it's day
four of the African spear project and
once again it is bitterly cold
[Music]
so there we go there's my first one and
the second one that I redid
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
okay I've been having repeated problems
with my drift heating up too much and
then getting also off is on me the key
is I've got to hit it once maybe twice
and pull it off twist it put it back on
if I hit it three times you get stuck
then it overheats and Jack's it all up
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
well you can see what I'm going for
there I'm about 3/4 of the way done and
I am exhausted
I've been nailing this thing for hours
well it's been a long day at work and
the Sun is setting and I am getting
ready to fire up the forge again I'm
gonna try something a little different
I'm actually gonna try heating my Forge
with coal I've been using charcoal for a
long time but it's really kind of
expensive I was getting it for five to
six dollars for a 15 pound bag of
charcoal but now the price is kind of
gone up to about twelve to fifteen
dollars a bag really expensive and I
just found a place that sells 40 pound
bags of coal for about six dollars and
change so I'm gonna try coal and see how
that goes but I've never actually run
coal in this board so we'll see how that
goes
[Music]
[Music]
cool
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
well I've worked on this for about two
and a half three hours and I've got the
drift punched up as deep as I think it's
gonna get and I've drawn it out about
50% of the way but I'm gonna go inside
and put the kids to bed so we're gonna
call it for tonight but man I should
love this call it heats up the metal
superfast and it's about 80% cheaper
than charcoal is right now so yeah we're
we're gonna be using coal in the future
time to get this Forge rolling guys cuz
it's arm day I'm a big problem right now
is that this is caca this materials
really thick on this side of the cone
and really thin here so I've got to try
to spread this out and then bend it so
there's less of a bow in there
[Music]
[Music]
but we're getting really close on the
javelin end of the spear I just need to
kind of spread out the material the cone
is really thin on one side and really
thick on the other and it's not quite in
line with the rest of the shaft
I really don't know if this cup is
sufficient enough to hold the weight of
the spirit not break off so I cut down
this tree here and I'm going to really
quick mount this and just test it out
and see how it does
well guys I'm really glad I did this
experiment and I learned a few things
first off the cup is deep enough 3/4
inches of cup is apparently good enough
it seems to sit really well maybe plenty
strong
however the spearhead is too heavy this
thing weighs close to 2 pounds and
pitching this spear even without the
second head on it it's really heavy and
it's man it takes a bit of muscle to
throw it so I think it should be about
half this weight additionally the
bulging tip that I put on here I think
it's just hurting performance it's just
not as getting that good of penetration
I just don't know what I'm gonna get a
chance to do this project over again and
I just don't want to have any regrets
this time so I'm really considering just
bagging it and starting over again
it's day 4550 three of the African spear
project and I am starting over on the
javelin portion and I've got a nice big
piece of leaf spring
[Music]
in stormy weather I might have abused
but nothing ever stop
for sure
[Music]
falling to the ground
when read stop sitting down
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
no sunshine
Oh
[Music]
yeah that looks pretty darn good to me
Wow well guys I am really glad I redid
this the cup turned out awesome I just
really think this is gonna be much
better looking it's gonna perform better
all right guys final day of forging all
I've got to do is take the angle grinder
and cut off the excess material clean up
the shaft a little bit put a point on
this baby and we are done with forging
[Music]
[Music]
I am so jazzed about how these turned
out I'm really glad I went and redid my
first attempts I'm gonna put this up for
the night it's dinner time and we're
gonna pick this up tomorrow
polishing these up then we got to heat
treat them and I got to make a shaft
[Music]
alright guys I've got a three gallon jug
of peanut oil here and I put some in my
my tube here for quenching the spearhead
do you know what has a pretty similar
coefficient of heat as motor oil so it
should cool the steel about the same
rate
however it's cold out and so the the
peanut oil has turned into a bit of a
gel not sure that matters so I'm going
to test a little bit but one of the
reasons I switched to the peanut oil is
it's just a lot less of a mess it's
easier to get rid of when you're done
with it and if you spill it it's not as
nasty on your lawn and stuff
[Music] [Applause]
[Music]
me and if you
[Applause]
we
[Music]
[Applause]
but when it comes to
[Music]
if they made you think
and if you reckon you're in trouble
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
guys I've got both heads on this thing
it looks and feels sick I cannot wait to
test this out I am so glad I read to
this project this looks so much better
that African mahogany is absolutely
breathtaking and I'm so pleased with how
the cups turned out now I know I'm gonna
get a lot of comments from people asking
why I didn't put some sort of locking
mechanism or pins in the cups and I'll
tell you why I don't think it needs it
these things are on super tight as you
drive the shaft into the cup you can
actually see the metal expand slightly
as it accepts the shaft but we need to
test this thing out and see how how it
throws I have spent many many days
working on this project now comes the
fun part I'm gonna throw this spear at
Bucky the deer over here yeah that would
that deep into the deer target
well my accuracy leaves something to be
desired but look at that that's close to
ten inches of penetration there that's
pretty awesome for something that I
threw by hand guys I had so much fun
making this video I hope you enjoyed it
too if you want to see more great videos
from the outdoor boys YouTube channel
don't forget to click subscribe that's
right thanks for watching we hope you
guys enjoyed this video if you'd like to
see more great videos from the outdoor
boys YouTube channel don't forget to
click subscribe we put out new videos
every week and don't forget to hit that
Bell button so you'll get notified when
we put out another great video